this statement from sources close to
Gary lineker I think is quite revealing
in a number of ways it's our
understanding is that they're fairly
confident that the matter will be
resolved and the keywords are to his
satisfaction within the next 24 hours
now obviously there are a number of ways
that you could interpret that but I
think the smart money would potentially
be on his satisfaction meaning some sort
of resolution perhaps even tweaks to the
guidelines of the BBC that would allow
him to do the two things that he wants
we know he wants to do which is continue
to present match of the day and other
things on the BBC but also be free to
say what he wants on his social media
he's long considered himself a
freelancer he does work for BT Sport for
Walkers aside from his work for the BBC
he wants as such he feels like he has a
part of his life it is not just the BBC
on his Twitter account he doesn't
reference the BBC and he feels like he
should be able to say what he likes on
that so we might
gather from what sources are telling Sky
News that his satisfaction would
presumably involve something along those
lines and I think it was fairly obvious
as the weekend developed and as this
crisis rumbled on that a landing Zone if
you like was coming into view Tim Davey
hinted at it yesterday he talked about
reflecting on the guidelines themselves
it was quite a turnaround really from 24
hours prior to that when they'd been
very clear that Gary lineker had broken
the guidelines and then he should be
staying away from political issues 24
hours later the director general of the
BBC was in listening mode he was
reflecting a number of former BBC wise
heads even today have said that the
obvious solution to this is some kind of
redrafting of the guidelines that might
just rely a little bit more leeway to
Freelancers to those presenters at the
BBC who are in areas other than news
whether that's sport or nature or or
popular programs like The Apprentice
thinking of someone like Alan sugar so
perhaps that is where the landing Zone
will be the only thing to say to that is
well if that is the case and if Gary
lineker is back on the BBC in a matter
of days well what is the reaction going
to be from those parts of the country
who were very angry with what he said in
the first place what will conservative
back Ventures be saying in the House of
Commons next week what will be the
headline on The Daily Mail and the other
newspapers that were quite vociferous in
their condemnation of Gary lineker and
that is a battle that presumably if the
BBC has come to this decision they're
going to have to be prepared to fight
because if it is the decision and again
we have to stress that we don't know
that all we have is this language from
sources close to Gary lineker that the
situation will be resolved to his
satisfaction so if we interpret his
satisfaction as meaning something along
those lines well then the BBC and Gary
lineker are going to have a heck of a
fight on their hands as soon as this
becomes public and the knowledge of the
deal is out in the open because I think
it's fairly clear that there was a
vociferous reaction to what he said and
that's not going to have uh dissipated
overnight just because the BBC and Gary
linear have come to some sort of
arrangement so look we wait to see
exactly what it is but once again worth
reiterating that sources close to Gary
lineker telling Sky News tonight that
they are confident that the situation
will be resolved to his satisfaction
within the next 24 hours and I think the
best way we can interpret that at this
stage with all the caveats I've just
outlined is that it may be a Gary
lineker returned to the BBC in some
format that will allow him to continue
to do what he says he's always done
which is speak out on the issues that
matter to him
and Matthew in the meantime do we have
any more information about future
programming because we've seen slimmed
Down versions of match of the day uh
match of the day two also this evening
do we know what's likely to happen with
future programming bearing in mind that
that staff have decided to support Gary
lineker thus far
will look all eyes have to be on Match
of the day too tonight uh where there
was every expectation that it would
follow a similar format to a match of
the day last night which that it was
basically devoid of all the usual
trappings of match of the day as it's
come to be known and loved across the
country there was no traditional iconic
theme tune there was no commentary there
was no punditry whatsoever it was it
wasn't even called match of the day it
was simply called Premier League
highlights and it was vastly reduced in
its duration down to 20 minutes from the
usual over an hour so we are expecting
that match the day Tuesday night will
follow a similar format we've seen the
disruption to the BBC schedules today
Radio 5 live has had to for a second day
running now I had to fill holes in its
schedule with podcasting although it has
at some some moments returned to the
usual uh fare and and has had commentary
on a number of important Premier League
matches ending the Six Nations as well
we've seen disruption to the women in
Super League on bbc2 and right across
the BBC BBC Scotland Services as well
disrupted so I think until there is a
clear resolution we have to assume that
that's going to continue that until
there is concrete uh agreement between
Gary lineker and the BBC that he will
come back or or whatever the resolution
is it may be that he will not come back
but I think that we can assume from his
statement or the statement from sources
close to him tonight that that is not
going to be the case but until there is
concrete resolution we have to assume
that disruption to the BBC's sporting
schedules will continue as it has done
for the last 48 hours